you have two movies scheduled for 2021
and 2023 yeah very excited when these
things were announced I have to ask you
are these two movies connected because
or are they completely separate things
really completely separate things
actually I just had two movie ideas in
my head felt very strong about it for me
there's a kind of I have all these ideas
and they're in journals sometimes and
there they don't quite have the meet yet
so they haven't whatever that thing is
that ineffable thing that makes it I'm
ready to come in two years in my life to
making this writing and directing this
and then promoting it it's some of those
ideas don't have those yet they just
have to just state a little bit but
there were two that I that I've been
thinking about that I was right away
these are these two I'm gonna make and
interestingly enough there might be a
third a third thing that came to me that
might end up going in between these two
so but what so there might be there
might be three that's first of all as a
fan of yours that's awesome yeah
second of all can you do you have titles
for any of these ah the first one have
you announced it or no no so you're not
gonna tell me no it's changed already
you from eat the last draft that I wrote
of it had a title and I'm announcing of
slightly altering the title in the in
the six draft of it got it and my last
thing for you um you you how do you
think these films that you're making
compared to the ones you've made before
yeah is there anything that is is one of
them radically different do they have a
similar like sort of knights truck you
don't I mean yeah well I'm loving this
approach from the visit on which is
minimal contained I own them we take big
risks tonal risks and we go to try to
hit that note of absurd but grounded
that that that dark humor moment and
deal with some complicated things and
not necessarily take the audience where
they're comfortable both during it or
even at the end and but that's all
mitigated because we're making it for a
responsible number and I feel like I'm
being a good partner to my distributors
and I like that because it allows me to
iterate really fast in in the making of
these stories so
those films will follow that that
architecture of approach of process if
even if it's even it's me tricking me
myself into being more dangerous it's
it's working because I feel when I think
about these three films that I'm
thinking about they're all weird and
dark and and I think that they all speak
to each other a little bit so hopefully
serving will make you go oh wow I yeah
right there was a formalism to Betty
Buckley's character and where she worked
in split oh wow I see all these common
threads that are coming in underneath
the piece so hopefully they they they're
good to each other brothers and sisters
I gotta go but that's the thing that I
think a lot of people don't realize if
you're making a film for a lower budget
you can do whatever the f you want
that's that's really my philosophy yeah
totally um can't wait thank you so much
for everything and this was great thanks
brother